yeah okay I'm just gonna put this down
here just this captures it's like just
back up okay okay so so where'd you grow
up and when you were a child what did
you want to be when you grew up I had no
idea what I wanted to be and I think
there's a language and it's good not to
know there was a time when my my heart
was set on raising horses I grew up
riding horses and I also believe it or
not from width for about two or three
years where I kind of wanted to be Annie
Oakley you know I'd like you know barrel
race horses but there weren't any sort
of grand intellectual models in my
childhood which is fun I'm even way I
had no expectations about you know
college and things like that which
probably liberated
when did you move out of texas when i
went off to college so and i was the
first person in my family to go to the
University so I went to I went to Emory
University in Atlanta Georgia which is
as far away as my parents would let me
go there was no possibility of going you
know up East and my father was in fact
horrified that there was no football
team at Emory so that tell she's
something is he a big Cowboys Longhorn
he was Ryu and how did you get how did
you first get interested in what you're
doing now yeah yeah what I do now a
historian of philosophy and I really
came to philosophy through a roundabout
means I was always interested in kind of
visual things and so when I got to
college I just struck by the history of
art and I really want this idea
studying especially the combination of
painting or physics and architecture so
I was really grabbed by our history and
went to Florence in fact for a few
months and it was actually studying in
Florence that completely changed my eyes
I had gotten to you know the university
without I really didn't know very much
about the world at all and so and I
guess I kind of thought behind for a
while other people who know that read
great books and so on and I was always
really impressed by that but had done
some myself and so when I got to
Florence there was something about the
it was just such a perfect site as it
turns out philosophical or his art
historical and just cultural
combinations of things and so I realized
at that point that if I read a lot and
looked a lot that I could you know I
could really get it get it get a whole
on some basic ideas that we're both
exciting and I realized I could find
and what I didn't know at the time is
that that was really that was really
history so I studied art history I
started reading around in philosophy I
took a little philosophy at the end of
my undergraduate
time and then went back to Italy for a
while and real and again did a little
philosophy and then just suddenly got
interested so I was lucky enough to get
into the ground I honestly to this day
they made a mistake about I have no idea
how they wound up except except he be
given that I had done that much of the
recipe and wanted to be an artist art
historian / his join a philosophy in
philosophy one out did you go straight
from college to graduate school no i
didn't i spent a lot i actually in fact
a professor in graduate school called me
believe it or not an academic gypsy
because i had done I had been in Europe
a couple of years I taught in Rome for a
year just with me I think I was a
millionaire I made four million lira a
month this is way back before the hero
and so I kind of live from hand to mouth
for a year in Rome and studied Latin
in fact one of my favorite moments in
that those days was that is the only I
was the only non non non priest and an
upper level Latin class taught by a man
who's now become famous Reginald Foster
who taught these advanced lab classes
and we would track around
you know read Latin together so that was
just a fabulous year and that's more
than anything else what convinced me to
go into to do serious study of history
sounds feel a lot of London you said
everybody kind of dreams but again I'll
summary I would really like to again so
when I got to graduate school I was a
little bit well really very unusual I'm
into a good program and I had done this
kind of touchy-feely you know art
history interested in history philosophy
and it worked out you know obviously but
at the time I just thought this was one
more big experiment
and how did you come to columbia i moved
to columbia actually had a job in the
California system and I took a slight
cut in salary to come to columbia have
to say which some friends of my thought
work was insane but I really loved New
York I liked the idea of because of
Europe because I do research in summers
and also i really like the idea of
teaching the core curriculum you know
i'm given my background there's kind of
interdisciplinary tendency i have i
thought was really nicely met by and
what to do with
so in fact when I first got the job here
people were surprised philosophy
department were surprised that i wanted
to teach you at home as opposed to CC CC
is more philosophical but that you know
against suited me and I have you know I
haven't been sorry really there's issues
about living in New York sometimes with
children and I I'm its it sounds like
you even Justin's like your background
kind of relates to the core curriculum
and that you try to capture a little bit
of everything moving into moving up from
I guess the general areas check
something more specialized yeah exactly
and one thing that one thing that
happened to me when I when I got tenure
I remember having this kind of
revelatory experience i thought you know
i am so boring for about the past six
years all I've done is my own research
you know I've only done my sixteenth and
seventeenth century philosophers you
know these these these early books and
Latin and with all these heavy duty
ideas and so when I got tenure I thought
you know what I can do I can actually
spend time now remembering quiet like to
art history all these things so i
started teaching art humanities and
really became more interested in trying
to integrate some of the parts of the
course so that i'm teaching that home
starting you know next week the first
semester of let home and i'm already
thinking about it differently than I did
the first time I talked about years ago
because of this relation like I now have
again with art history so I'm really
excited about again bringing these
things together this is gonna how many
years have you taught in the quarter
well I've been at Columbia it's really
scary i've been at columbia now what is
it 15 16 years and i bet I'm except when
I've been on leave and I think at 1 year
when I was busy with committee work I
think I've taught a semester of the core
every single semester so I've been as
mostly been lick'em and art home I give
I give Korra left I give lectures to CC
because my area
Descartes and the scientific so I've
been pretty involved in the core and as
I think you know you know one of the
things that I've been moving into in my
research I have this book series I'm
going to be the general editor of this
book series Oxford philosophical
concepts and that's each book is going
to be a collection concept and history
philosophy mostly European velocity and
its transformations but one of the
things that's happened really becoming
solely because of my work your core and
is those books are going to be very
interdisciplinary they're going to be
what we're going to call sign notes
which are written by non philosophers on
topics from art history from literature
that impact philosophical ideas in ways
that we hope that both philosophers and
non philosophers were interesting and
that really is motivated by the success
of T of the kind of interdisciplinary
work that
that's so neat i remember when that came
out it just seems like them it seems
almost obvious and obviously no one's
really thought of it combined and I
philosophy that way or approaching Plus
that way which kind of you might have
stolen my next question but obviously
are you're working of my neck session
was what are you working on now is what
is this series taking up the majority of
your time outside teaching yeah so I
have I have like three book projects
which is kind of ridiculous and it's
ridiculous because I kind of moved from
one to the other to the other and so
once almost done and the other two are
you know almost almost done and the
reason they haven't quite gotten done is
because of the book series so the book
series really is taking up a huge amount
of time the reason I mean it's fun time
I get to correspond with great scholars
international scholars about how to
think about the medieval section
on evil or space or eternity and these
are really kind of fun things to have to
do and so that would take some time
anyway but what really is taking time is
that I mean the good news is that the
editors have been quite taken so these
are serious scholars and history
philosophy and they've been completely
taken by this idea of including these
interdisciplinary editions but the
question is how to do it and one thing
we've decided is that they can't be just
fun you know if you're doing a volume on
the virtues it might be really fun to
have just representations of the virtues
of the history of art or something and
that will probably be included by the
way but you want to find examples from
theater literature or maybe in some
cases if it's relevant in a Hindu views
of some of these issues that are
actually philosophically interesting and
approach the topic from a different
perspective so insofar as it's different
people have are having to think hard and
expand our imaginations really to do
that and do it well and so we're all
kind of working together to do that
and that is that's taking time do not
have to respond and I had to put them in
contact with people so while that's
really fun it really is some festive um
there are some nice fun questions I'm
Jim children I do it two boys 18 and 15
oh it's an exciting age the 18 year old
in high school or CD disc ready
eighteen-year-old actually graduated a
year early oh he's just started the
second year of Bennington Oh which is
really fabulous oh yeah yeah you know
from lots wonderful and he just he grew
up in the shadow of Columbia yeah so he
definitely wanted to get away and they
both have been committed to public
schools and i have to say at this point
you know they're practically so i just
have to attend attend to some food and
give me pets what's something this is
this question always done sorry i should
add when i send out the email i should
warn people but what's something that
your students would never guess about
you be at a hidden talent or great hobby
yeah basically i don't think i have any
talents whatsoever no they probably i
think they might be surprised and what
the books i work
the 17th century text because I try to
banking history philosophy I try to make
it kind of life away and not relevant in
the sense that it was about their
day-to-day life but I wanted to speak to
them and I think honestly if they saw
this or that he's dense Latin text
favorite people a little bit taken aback
since of you this will be running in
january i believe so what uh what would
you know what she'll be teaching next
semester will you be to do yeah i'll be
teaching philosophy and feminism open
and i may teach another core course in
the spring i'm hoping to be able to do a
whole year before this year I'm quite
interested in getting more involved
thinking about being a bit more so when
I want to think about this year I want a
lot of my attention this year
but my philosophy and feminism class is
my favorite classes I love it it's some
become very interested in feminist
issues I have been for a long time but
recently I realized that teaching
feminist issues is really a way of
engaging students and it's about
philosophically rich and I really think
that's politically some of our best
philosophy majors have come to
philosophy through this course they
didn't know they were interested taking
it and realizing if they're interested
in philosophy what a cool opportunity
for ya and it's just a fabulous again
great class with students I mean are you
know I have fun the students see me
Steven students come back two or three
or four years later and say how really
important it was for them in terms of
their development
believe it or not in philosophy we still
are pretty horrible in terms of numbers
of women in the profession
in fact just as summer 2020
so so all of the this is our gender
feminist side of my life is suddenly and
this semester you're ditching just lit
hum I'm teaching the come in a graduate
course okay the graduate course of funky
conversation well in fact a lot of two
or three of us have for a long time been
been worrying about no causal notions
and history philosophy that are really
important to the development of
philosophy that have not been taken
quite as seriously as they should have
because they're weird cause elimination
where something supremely good or
something that has ultimate be somehow
manages to be in all the things that
creates but not being part of them now
that's a really interesting
philosophical possible how can that work
and do some of the great minds industry
philosophy have thought some version of
that there's also this idea of
sympathetic universal harmony where you
know insofar as were all part of the
same rational system we're all in some
kind of sympathetic relationship
and this notion solved a lot of problems
that in physics and ethics and someone
is your philosophy but a lot of these
weird notions have been pushed aside and
not taking this seriously or not studied
as much because they're not like
anything what we believe now seems to be
seems to be quite alien to this way of
thinking so what develop out of the work
that smelled Lester knew is in fact as
the guy Eric Schlosser his friend mine
just started calling these notions funky
Mikey causation so I'm going to teach a
course on these cookies funky sounds
like fun it's a good tile how do you
recharge I actually go bike riding or
running I like I go jogging in the park
like my son's and have been really
involved in politics especially when we
were very involved in the Obama campaign
in the primaries and you know like went
to Texas for example so one of the
things we do is just sit around and talk
about like what's happening politically
and I love it because usually they know
a lot more than I do
and that somehow is nice for me but also
I you know you don't want to talk about
what kind of community work you do
because sounds like you know you're
you're suggesting that here in good soul
but in fact it really does cool my jets
and call me two columns me down in a
good way to be involved
just you not like to get outside
Columbia I wouldn't call it pathetic but
this is this the Sun I do I love running
in the park is my favorite parka so it's
such a blessing to live right next door
as well just to walk out your door and
be there oh if you could be anywhere in
the world right now where would you be
that's a really good question I mean I'd
love to be roam again for a while I'd
love to be with my son right now in this
first week of college is kind of you
know talk again about what he's doing
though he would probably not want me
there yeah I i love i love leaving a
class at classroom when I think I've
done a half decent job
that's always like that's one of my
favorite moments so maybe having just
being in that moment right now it would
be a great pleasure but I'm your resume
are you most proud of resume I mean you
know what professional accomplishments
right I really like I was very moved to
get the Great Teacher Award last year
and I think I'm a hard teacher I'm a
whore remember greater and tough and I
think the fact that students have
responded I think it really to this
philosophy feminism class I think they
like being pushed
I think I'm also very proud of my
children and what's your favorite food
oh my favorite we're getting to the
heart any question of the dances
possible chocolate cake what the or what
are you reading or what's the last
really good book you read not related to
work right well you know this it turns
out this is related to work but I read a
destroyed Toni Morrison's new book on
mercy which is just fabulous late movie
and I've decided that I didn't read it
with this in mind but I decided that
when I teach the second half of lit hum
again I'm leaving
it's short which is good coming at
needed with them but also you know it's
it's it's Toni Morrison's normal attempt
to be found in beautiful English
yeah I thought it was amazing and I mean
yeah I that book I've struggled with a
couple for books and a few I actually
fortunately went to a high school that
we read several for books in high school
it was a very diverse school and they
push that diverse curriculum but I mercy
was wonderful and on that note you're
teaching that as part of the mini course
can you just talk a little bit about the
mini course about right right yeah well
I have a lot to say about the core in
the sense that you know I think I think
it's really good for eighteen year
eighteen nineteen year olds but I also
think it's even better for 30 and 40
year olds and so one day of it one of
the great things about the core is that
it gives anyone who's been in Columbia
you know ten years later 20 years later
30 years later he gives them something
to talk about it
set in white values and concerns at
least intellectual values and so I
completely approved for me Deborah more
a really good job I think I'm pushing
the core in ways that will encourage a
read the books and study and think the
thoughts again but what I've been
completely struck by in the mini core
courses is is that instructed by the
fact that these people when they revisit
are even more moved
and they say that they say you know I
have no idea that montina my team is so
wonderful or so profound in this way I
just kind of annoying was 18 but also
you know my version of the mini course
is some kind of an attempt to do this
interdisciplinary work so the one I
taught last year apparently worked
somewhat well that we did I talked a
little bit about philosophy it kind of
set the philosophical contacts for then
something that they had read from that
hum one of the literature of humanities
text and then we looked at some images
from art huh and thatthat's have helped
visualize and helped us again see the
connection between
the philosophical and the students at
least Lisa people who signed up for this
class seemed to think it all worked and
so I'm going to try that again this year
and I'm going to do a mercy by toni
morrison and i decided to do art by Kara
Walker who is this really really out
there very interesting african-american
artists who does silhouettes in fact
there was a show of her work at the
Whitney
which was really interesting
it cooks up well especially with the
mercy it's very historical it's about
19th century images and sexuality and
often the abuse of a female slaves and
it's all of this stuff that's really
heavy and difficult but also some house
oddly and strangely beautiful which is
exactly what I think Tony Morrison spoke
so those are two those are going to
merge many courses one of the many
classes one final question I'm what's
your favorite spot in New York City um
the reservoir I think at this point so I
really like this incentive pretentious I
love to go to the Metropolitan Museum it
just wonder around us with those back
rooms or you know the tourists you
should never get so about the Pacific
island me or I just discovered the jab
so with the Japanese or
so I like to sort of just going some
clothes I haven't been or something
enormously I don't know there's
something really calming and inspiring
so so what I should do I know I guess
its run around the reservoir and then go
to the problem to combine two but I
guess I guess have you been I've even
out in central park lately in the
evening and seen raccoons yes I actually
saw a bunch I saw three of them crossing
central park west one night right going
into the bushes right at the castle at
10 fell yeah listen I got to tell you
what would have to be that I was running
in the park and these tourists were
sitting around going oh look look like
you know and I just thought that they
were worried at all gives a lot of birds
and there gawking it a bird or something
and it turns out there to their records
fornicating in the truck I guess I
should have this one we were out in the
middle of the woods that's pretty funny
well thank you so much Thanks yeah that
one Sue's I told you pretty highness it
was it's nice i have been uh my wife
works at lamont oh